Nous espérons que nous aurons une saison
prospérer
pour une raison quelconque, peu de gens viennent en Crimée
Il y a de si beaux endroits ici
[musique]
j'ai tout déchargé, vérifié la voiture
je suis entré dans tous les sacs à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
scanné Nous sommes passés par le scanner
puis chargé, passons à autre chose
[musique]
à l'heure actuelle, il y a certaines circonstances avec
opération spéciale, la plupart des gens sont très
C'est effrayant de venir ici et il semblerait que nous y soyons
nous sommes tous assis sur la plage en train de nous détendre maintenant
cool, tout semble calme mais essentiellement
ici derrière la clôture disons que c'est du bon voisinage
il y a des combats en cours, bien sûr, oui, c'est le cas
[musique]